hello everyone and welcome back to the
show that today we'll see a cavalcade of
cartoon carnage when dreamworks takes on
illumination why would we take a gaggle
of lovable humans creatures and
franchises and make them fight it out
for our amusement well the show is
called verses kind of what we do i'm
your host mark ellis and i'll be judging
this all out anthropomorphic animated
assault yes i nailed that sentence in
one take these are two of the biggest
animation studios in hollywood
responsible for tens of billions of
dollars at the box office and hundreds
of trillions of smiles across earth far
away land and whoville by the way
whoville and i cannot stress this enough
they got some serious issues going on
over there the grinch least of their
concerns in one corner it's dreamworks
the studio founded by three super rich
creatives that's blessed us with shrek
toothless and everyone's favorite
boss baby ah you thought i was gonna say
kung fu panda didn't you
maybe i should just quit and go back to
making noodles and in the other corner
it's illumination gentlemen cue the
phantom of the opera chandelier see i'm
cultured it's the studio that's regaled
us with adorable minions secretive pets
and of course the lorax ha ha you
thought i was gonna say scratch from ice
age didn't you interesting note about
that a couple of the ice age films share
some connectivity with illumination
which we will get into a little bit
later but they are not eligible for
competition today i don't care how many
acorns that squirrel gave me before the
show here's how we'll determine a winner
round one box office round two tomato
meter slash audience score round three
characters round four franchise ability
and then we'll do a wild card round that
illumination hopes will involve overalls
while dreamworks is crossing their
fingers that they can win you over with
cute sword-wielding kitties and now
here's my disclaimer the fact that i've
lasted this long without gushing about
how cute puss in boots is it's nothing
short of a miracle and it's probably
gonna happen a lot during this match
cause he's got his little hat
sorry mark suck it up millions of people
are watching this both studios make
films that blend quintessential kids
stories with humor for us adult folk
that has been pleasing family since the
late 90s but today only one can ram
supreme emerge victorious and advance to
play pixar the next round you know what
maybe we just teamed these two up
against pixar buzz and woody they tend
to bring the lumber but enough about
possessed dolls this is versus let's get
it on round one box office
go ahead and name your favorite animated
movie shout it at the tv or the phone or
computer monitor right now chances are
it did very well at the box office
audiences flock to big blockbusters
families pile in for animated flicks and
in the case of dreamworks and
illumination they tend to get the best
of both worlds even when one of their
films gets overshadowed such as the case
with ants the very first feature film
from dreamworks animation a bug's life
came out this same year courtesy of
pixar but ants also did well earning 172
million dollars worldwide back in 1998.
the next year prince of egypt would get
into the promised land of over 200
million dollars with a tinier budget and
the fledgling animation house had found
its formula then in 2001 a green ogre
and his pals showed up and so did
everyone to the movie theaters as shrek
called in 484 million bones around the
globe the sequel accurately titled shrek
2 set what is still the high bar for any
dreamworks project when it raked in 920
million dollars across the seven seas
shrek iii and shrek forever after also
performed well as both donkeyed their
way to over 700 million dollars each but
dreamworks was just getting warmed up
with its marketable properties
madagascar debuted in 2005 to the tune
of 533 million dollars kung fu panda
kicked off in 2008 with 632 million
dollars and in 2010 how to train your
dragon flossed up
495 million bucks oh and puss in boots
earned 555 million dollars largely
because of how adorable his tiny sword
is that flick was released in 2011 which
is just a year after illumination began
their run of hits but before we get to
the despicable mes there's that ice age
conundrum you see elimination founder
christopher melidandry was an executive
producer on the first two ice age films
then founded his own animation studio
illumination not to be confused with the
illuminati who had a good run below the
denver airport until scarlet witch
wrecked them all in about three minutes
so then we get the first despicable me
in 2010 and gru's evil genius paid off
to the tune of 543 million dollars then
despicable me 2 crushed in 2013 with a
970 million dollar worldwide take dark
helmet may have had a point when he said
evil always triumphs over good because
good is dumb
i can't breathe in this thing but if we
like crew we love the minions their
standalone film cleverly called minions
rung up 1.15 billion dollars in cash
registered jingles the next despicable
me flick would also cross the billion
dollar threshold but like dreamworks
illumination was never content to be a
one franchise pony the secret life of
pets and sing both kicked off with
monster numbers combining to make over
one and a half billion bucks and now dr
seuss checks into the ball game the
lorax and the grinch add up to an
additional 850 million in global revenue
so we got us a scrap on our hands but
here's what this round is going to come
down to quality or quantity dreamworks
and its decade-long head start certainly
has more bodies to throw into the fray
and after 42 films the studio's per
movie average is a whopping
369 million dollars and the grand sum
total of all those flicks is over 15
billion thanks boss baby
i kid the you know well kid but that
first double b movie took in 528 million
dollars kids they really are the future
it's obvious illumination can't compete
in total box office revenue they only
have 11 movies to date that have added
up to just over 7 billion dollars but
that per movie average is jaw dropping
645 million dollars every time a new
film is released that beats the
wisecracking baby by over 100 million
dollars and sealing the deal is
frugality while the typical dreamworks
picture costs around 116 million the
usual illumination flick just 75 million
i really don't see how we can afford
this so we make more per motion picture
yet it costs us less to put that picture
into motion it feels like an upset win
in round one but illumination gets the
point and goes up on dreamworks one to
nothing round two tomato meter slash
audience score
so dreamworks finds itself in a somewhat
surprising hole after round one simply
because how could anyone top the box
office clout of shrek donkey fionna and
again that amazing cat and i'm a dog
person saying this round two might be
another uphill climb for the works
simply because they've made so many more
movies than illumination and the more
flicks you put out the more chances they
have to fall into
rotten territory don't believe me just
ask steven seagal
if you can find out where he is for
elimination they've been the new
darlings on the animation block for the
last decade and much like their box
office results the critical reaction to
these flicks has been solid gru kicked
us off with tons of promise as
despicable me now part one notched 81 on
the tomato meter and its immediate
sequel stands tall at 75 percent so
that's good news the bad news is that
those are the highest rated films in the
entire illumination batch shockingly the
pair of theodor geisel movies are both
rotten with the grinch at 59
and the war racks at 54
theo also went by the moniker dr seuss
was he a real doctor
doesn't matter we love him but maybe
consult an actual physician before
ingesting green eggs trust me kids this
is the voice of experience dreamworks
has an opening now and looks poised to
take full advantage how's this for a
start all three how to train your dragon
movies are at 90 or above on the tomato
meter the first one is at 99
begging the question of what critic was
bit by a dragon when they were young the
second is 91 percent and the third the
hidden world is at a 90
even score dreamworks continues to pile
it on with chicken run at 97 percent
wallace and gromit curse of the wear
rabbit at 95 percent and even ants
marching its way to a 92 percent fun
fact time ansa's bitter rival of bugs
life is also at 92
look it's been over 20 years can we bury
the hatchet and make these movies
friends
no
i tried when we combined both studios
and cinnamon toast the numbers it's not
great news for team light bulb
dreamworks can boast about having all 10
movies in the top 10 of either house on
the meter day tomato that's thanks to
the first kung fu panda and captain
underpants films both of whom reside at
87 percent and shrek 2 and 89 percent
besting its predecessor by a mere 1
curiously it's also shrek in the gang
who owned the lowest tomato meter score
for dreamworks as shrek the third is it
just 41 what happened in that movie is
steven seagal doing the voice of shrek
in that one but even that numeral is
considerably higher than illumination's
low bar which is 24 percent care to
guess the flick here's a hint it
features a set of animals known for
their weeping ability and their neck for
procreation hop while the easter classic
is the outlier here not even the minions
could bob their way into fresh waters
that movie is 55
and despicable me 3 is at 59
all told dreamworks dominates the law of
averages here garnering 72.4 percent for
an average movie toppling illuminations
usual of 61.9 percent freshness all
around but one is clearly using that
natural deodorant so let's head on over
to the audience score where illumination
does have some firepower the sequels
sing 2 and the secret life of pets 2 are
both above 90
and the lowest flick here would be
oh no really it's minions
really just 49
what was the audience expecting i'm
sorry didn't have daniel day lewis
sewing clothes in it but that's still
better than dreamworks's all-time low
shark tale at 45 on the audience score
really again look the movie's called
shark tale what was the problem it's
over you're old school our expert
researcher mark hoffmeier took a break
from watching fight scenes in bathrooms
that was a real thing he did to provide
you all with this tidbit we combined the
studios again and illumination still
only has two of the top 10 movies
according to the audience score
dreamworks has abominable and spirit
untamed at 95 percent on this metric and
their overall average per flick is 71.8
percent besting illuminations 68.9 so
now the only question that remains is
how puss and boots do 86 fresh on the
tomato meter and 67 on the audience
score which is a little too low for my
taste but i'm not going to pick another
fight with the loyal viewers of this
show again i am sorry that sharktail
didn't have enough talking farm animals
for you all dreamworks gets on the board
in convincing fashion in round two and
we got us a brawl it's one to one as we
head into
round three characters
okay yes puss and boots will be a major
factor here but i'll try to be as
unbiased as i can i'm also a dog person
and i do love the grinch's dog max so
that should even things out somewhat
after all we were only blessed with sir
lord boots thanks to shrek which is
actually a wonderful place to start this
round the titular ogre may have gotten
the butts into seats but this franchise
is an ensemble lover's paradise donkey
voiced by the incomparable eddie murphy
and fiona played by cameron diaz
headline a stunning array of
complimentary folks ranging from john
lithgow's lord farquaad to julie andrews
as the queen come on that's a-list
heaven ironically it was shrek who was
the most confounding voice to cast for
reasons both light and tragic originally
the role was going to go to chris farley
who even did vocal work for the big
green guy prior to his untimely passing
then fellow snl castmate mike myers
stepped in but didn't do his scottish
brogue initially it was more or less
just mike myers and it was dr evil who
after hearing his sessions requested to
redo the character in scottish which
ended up costing dreamworks around 5
million dollars i guess because
microphones are expensive but come on
did you see the box office round they
made out pretty all right in the end but
shrek would be far from the only
tentpole available to spielberg geffen
and katzenberg see
i knew their names i also know poe
monkey viper tigress mantis and the rest
of the kung fu panda brigade each role
brings a unique energy to the
proceedings which is probably why the
franchise has been so successful you got
the comedic chops of jack black and seth
rogen the ass hickory of lucy lou and
jackie freaking chan and the oscar
prowess of angelina jolie plus
jean-claude van damme voices a crocodile
and kung fu panda too it really is the
gift that keeps on giving if you're
still wrestling over whether you love
dogs or cats more maybe meet in the
middle with a cute little dragon hiccup
voiced by jay barachel and toothless the
dragon are such a wonderful boy in his
dog pairing that the film just seems to
get better and better america ferrara
and gerard butler are two more examples
why dreamworks is doing it right when it
comes to voicing animated characters but
illumination hit hard right out of the
gate by landing steve carell for the
voice of felonious gru the star of the
daily show then hit films like anchorman
and bruce almighty as well as the office
carell ditched his usual baritone for a
less relatable dialect but the gamble
paid off not only do we get to see both
how evil and how fatherly gru can be he
was also the conduit who introduced us
to the minions bob carl darwin and the
rest of the enormous population are
experts at comedy relief but they can
also lead their own film when necessary
having said that if you are going to
strike out on your own as a headliner it
helps having sandra bullock voice the
lead diabolical human as backup danny
devito is the lorax and benedict
cumberbatch is the grinch where home run
hits as well and while devito seems like
the ultimate no-brainer in terms of
sushi and creature casting the studio
also didn't dawdle for long before going
after dr strange it was cumberbatch's
sherlock roll however that sealed the
deal they wanted to go deeper into the
grinch's backstory so they needed
someone who could handle both grief
comedy and dark tendencies with a plum
you know kind of like that detective
fella kevin hart and jenny slate are
just two of the comedic standouts from
the secret life of pets and if you like
a big cast sing would have us here all
day so i'll simply mention that matthew
mcconaughey is the voice of a koala bear
enjoy how would you pull yourself
together and please blow that nose of
yours
but back to dreamworks for their ace in
the hole it's time for me to full-on
gush look at the little kitty in his
tiny boots and he's got the little hat i
want to snuggle him but that was far
from the original concept of this feline
producers first had artwork of a heavier
cat inspired by 19th century french
artist gustave dore's rendering of a
kitty with a belt full of dead mice and
a necklace sporting beaks nice gifts
though they may be once antonia bandera
stepped into the role they favored the
inspiration from another banderas
character zorro the playful movements
the cocky charisma twas the charm
radiating from antonio that gave us the
puss in boots that we all know love and
embarrass ourselves fawning over
i'll kill that guy in a round that's on
outnumbered illumination put up quite
the fight i gotta lean on dreamworks for
its vast array of diverse characters
ranging from humans to animals to troll
dolls and the kid fishing on the moon
goes up two to one round four franchise
ability
ah yes i do love a round that is titled
by a word that archaeologists believe
was invented by me mark ellis
franchisability likely first used way
back in the geozoic era of 2018 on this
very show and now it pertains to two
studios that have proven to have a
penchant for churning movies out that
are so beloved we just got to make more
of them hence be getting a franchise
here's the rub each studio must select
one of their tentpole talking picture
monoliths to duke it out here well
technically it's going to be me the guy
who invented franchise ability doing the
selection in a move that should level
the playing field after all dreamworks
has had 12 extra years to make
blockbuster flicks into sequels and
trilogies but illumination may not even
need that break they have the sings the
secret life of pets and i guess we could
lump in dr seuss as one big franchise
but the easy answer here would be
despicable me that's what's going to be
entering the cage in this round and now
we look to dreamworks for their champion
it's quite the list to choose from
obviously we can go with shrek but how
to train your dragon is up there too as
is kung fu panda madagascar even the
croods can stake a claim but if i gotta
go with the most profitable illumination
franchise here fair play would indicate
that i select shrek and his gaggle of
goose to enter the fray on his studio's
behalf what is the better franchise
shrek or despicable me
[Music]
shrek has so much room for storytelling
because it takes place in a fairy tale
land and if any of you watching used to
be children you know that's pretty
fertile ground for characters don't
believe me just ask the company that has
all those theme parks around the world
meanwhile despicable me has seen its
star continue to rise because it's more
relatable to us here on earth stay with
me people i'm not talking about the evil
billionaire genius villain dad thing but
it's the family dynamic at play that
continues to give gru his daughters and
the minions purpose sure he can be
wretched as a human but that's just his
job we all hate our job but we do it so
that our kids can lead better lives than
we ever could
unless you're me because i don't have
children and this is my job
it's pretty fun but still there was one
other franchise i was tempted to pick
over shrek madagascar yeah i just said
that because of the spin-off potential
those penguins from madagascar had their
own hit movie and they're great
like i love the penguins but shrek also
had a spin-off character that needs no
introduction it's the kitty who really
could have looked like grumpy cat with
the bones of his victims around his
waist man french arches hit's different
luckily puss in boots is much more
lovable and could carry on the shrek
franchise in new exciting ways but even
that fancy feast chowing puddy cat
couldn't match the might of the minions
they are simple yet adorable and what
they lack an individual skill they make
up for in sheer numbers they may not be
the brightest bulbs or the most worthy
thought provokers but there's too many
of them to ignore and that especially
comes into play when we talk about
yogurt from spaceballs his favorite word
merchandising where their real money
from the movie is made their merch sales
are in the billions stratosphere hell i
even won a minion basketball by shooting
three successful three-pointers in a row
at universal studios i wanted for my
girlfriend at the time she didn't want
it i kept it anyway and we are no longer
together shrek has obviously crushed it
in the merch game as well but none of
those characters can keep pace with a
demand for the tiny yellow eraser heads
and the movies themselves don't seem to
be slowing down we got another
despicable me this summer and while the
jury is out on whether we get another
shrek or counting crow's cover of a
monkey song the green ogre had an
amazing run for 10 years but get this
now despicable me has had a longer jog
than shrek and puss start to finish and
gru looks like he can keep the pace
going a while longer look i'd love
nothing more than to see shrek fiona
donkey and booties which is what i call
the cat back on the big screen but as of
now the franchise ability seems to be
strongest with despicable me keep up the
great work minions but look out for
those penguins don't sleep in that movie
y'all those monogamous rascals are
hysterical illumination gets the point
though and we're tied 2-2 and now it's
time for the wild card round iconic
moments these are the scenes sequences
and scenarios that have made us laugh
cry and cough up popcorn seeds because
of whatever was going on with us that
day before we begin the deciding round
of this match i have a question what
makes you the home viewer cry the most
with either one of these studios besides
how much bigger their bank account is
than ours once the movie the moment that
got y'all misty-eyed for me it seems to
be at least halfway through every dragon
training adventure that my emotions are
feeling the need to express themselves
through my eyeballs hiccup and toothless
reminds me of myself and molly the
wonder dog but it's also the noble
ending for stoic who sacrificed himself
to save hiccup that funeral hits hard
and as far as cartoon wakes go it's
gotta be right up there with anything
it's the saddest thing since the honey
smacks frog died
oh he's still alive oh good for him
carry on dig him dig him historically
emotions can run long in animated films
in a tradition paved by disney murdering
a family member five minutes into every
classic or by pixar showing us how a
guy's wife died horribly before
launching a house into the sky with
balloons oddly for illumination it's the
two characters who might be the most
villainous that get my tear ducts ready
gru and the grinch there's some real
heartstrings being pulled with the
grinch's backstory and seeing him
bullied makes me want to turn whoville
into the next alderaan speaking of the
dark side felonious crew has it in
spades but he also loves his little
girls and he's had his own trying
backstory as a youth with neighborhood
ruffians but let's get real no one shows
up to these movies hoping to weep
uncontrollably that's just an unexpected
byproduct of how invested we get with
these characters and their moments by
and large we roll up to the multiplex on
opening night hoping for lots of laughs
and shrek doesn't have any character
that can't conjure up the laugh right on
command mike myers and cameron diaz have
starred in some of the biggest
live-action comedies ever yet they're
usually playing it straight to the
antics of donkey the gingerbread
suffering is always a welcome sight for
some sick reason and of course i'd be
remiss if i didn't highlight the first
time we see puss in boots do the sad
eyes in shrek 2. kung fu panda is here
for laughs as evidenced by the befi of
squadoo shelps but the fight scenes in
that franchise are top-notch as well the
first film has an epic prison break
sequence and part two features an
all-time showdown against the conniving
shin voiced by gary oldman guy's pretty
good at playing baddies megamind also
had some thrilling extravagance and a
killer soundtrack and here's a deep cut
for you the red sea parting in prince of
egypt did that actually happen
i don't know but i'm pretty sure real
penguins can't fly planes so maybe just
relax and enjoy the ride the minions
make me laugh so hard i almost popped my
hernia stitches and the bulk of those
giggles were in their own stand-alone
adventure bob as an england monarch them
stuck in prison it just keeps getting
better and speaking of rocking
soundtracks don't think this mighty van
halen fan missed that scene near the end
when one of them wails on an electric
guitar and teases us with a few notes
from eruption anyone else pick that up
i might be the only one well you really
got me with that reference anyway but
whereas with sing and trolls and their
bevy of cuddly characters the iconic
moments are just mainly fun music videos
on the other side of the street is
dreamworks and they have tons more
movies to rely on for great memories
like hunting with the croods the epic
fight or flight moment in chicken run or
really anything in a wallace and grommet
tale i'll take that wear rabbit over hop
any day so as great as the premise for
something like the secret life of pets
is and as much as i do love watching a
dog go to town inside of a hot dog
factory the vault of greatness from
dreamworks is just too much for the
legacy of illumination to handle keep
cranking out more minions and we might
have a real battle here but as of now
dreamworks gets the deciding point and
thus wins the match three to two all the
propers in the world go to illumination
they've picked and choose their spots
wisely with reliable family
entertainment for over a decade now and
i hope they keep going back to the dr
seuss well but re-watching the shreks
shark tale how to train your kung fu
pandas it was just so much fun disney
and pixar may still be a top mount
olympus when it comes to animated
features but dreamworks and illumination
have constructed quite a resume in their
young life not to brag or rather with
the intention of bragging i also want a
basketball game at disneyland but i just
gotta stop the animal as a prize that i
believe was a drunken mr toad i got to
go back to the happiest place on earth
and see what that situation is now well
the prize today goes to dreamworks
thanks to mike myers eddie murphy
cameron diaz and all the other
luminaries who didn't show up today and
probably aren't aware that i'm talking
about them but you won congrats really
to bose studios on a fun episode and now
it's your turn dear viewer which set of
films do you prefer let me know on
social media at mark ellis live and keep
it right here at rotten tomatoes for all
the latest in the world of movies tv and
fairy tales this has been versus i was
mark ellis and remember there is no
secret ingredient only you
and maybe cayenne pepper
you